bonjour les efforts merci bonjour
invités politiques ce matin puis
secrétaire du parti socialiste soutient
évidemment d'anne hidalgo on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes d'interview
en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour cassel
bertrand bonjour en réalmont jour
arriver ça bonjour à l'hôtel du groupe
la dépêche
on commence par un mot sur l'ukraine
olivier faur négociations hier entre
russie et ukraine des pourparlers
qualifiée de significative de positif
part volodymyr zélande ce crime et y a
pas de cessez-le-feu pas de couloirs
humanitaires
emmanuel macron appelle à maintenir la
pression sur vladimir poutine il a
raison oui il faut être prudent à
l'avenir poutine on sait que il a subi
des revers important sur le terrain et
que la résistance ukrainienne lui a
infligé de lourdes pertes matérielles et
humaines qu'il est obligé de faire au
moins une pause son
sens en soutenant son offensive et donc
il ya peut-être une dimension tactique
aussi 7 à cet effort diplomatique mais
il faut évidemment aussi espérer le
meilleur et vous croyez ce matin une
sortie diplomatique de ce conflit
rapidement je ne sais pas si moi je ne
croit à rien je veux voir en fait je
veux être sûr que les choses se passent
est ce que j'observe en revanche c'est
que on a un président ukrainien dont on
avait dit qu'il était extrémistes qui
étaient parfois le problème autant que
la solution et on voit aujourd'hui à
quel point il est prêt à aménager son
propre pays ménagers y compris la
relation avec la russie pour parvenir à
un accord et éviter le pire alors
justement ce président et craignant la
demande et surtout ne pas lever les
sanctions tout de suite est-ce qu'on
peut les maintenir et combien de temps
sans qu'ils aient un impact fort sur le
pouvoir d'achat des français
il faut les maintenir parce qu'on voit
bien que c'est aussi un des éléments de
la pression sur le régime
russe et donc qu' il serait illusoire de
considérer que si on baisse la garde
maintenant tout va bien se passer si la
cie la réaction des européens n'avaient
pas été aussi forte ce que la dîme à
poutine n'imaginait pas une seule
seconde il était habitué
mais europe qui est toujours en faux
semblant toujours dans une forme
d'hypocrisie condamnant mais n'allons
pas jusqu'au bout de la sanction cette
fois-ci et s'est retrouvé dans une
situation où il s'est rencontré s'est
heurté à un mur et c'est ce mur qui
aujourd'hui le fait en partie reculée
donc le mur ils craignent un parce que
c'est sur le plan militaire c'est
compliqué mais aussi sur le plan
diplomatique sur le plan de son
isolement international se sont
résolument économique et c'est vrai que
c'est aussi alors c'est un c'est une une
exigence de solidarité à l'idée que les
européens doivent être assez en
direction des ukrainiens mais nous
devons ça aussi notre propre sécurité et
nous le devons aussi et notre propre
à notre propre raison d'être que serait
l'europe si elle n'était plus que
finalement un vaste ensemble qui est
incapable de défendre ses valeurs à ses
propres frontières et sûre sur les
conséquences sur le pouvoir d'achat vous
demande aux entreprises françaises de
quitter la russie est ce qu'il va pas y
avoir des conséquences sur les emplois
en france sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français ces sanctions vont trop lente
décathlon vient de le faire renault l'a
fait je vois que il ya s'attendre une
entreprise qui ont pris conscience que
le dilemme qu'elle avait il faut
comprendre le dilemme qui existe il ne
s'agit pas de nature dans une forme de
déni et de considérer que je serai sans
importance ça évidemment des
conséquences mais à un moment dans la
vie il ya des choix qui sont douloureux
mais il faut les prendre parce que tout
simplement ils permettent d'avancer et
donc à force de reculer nous avons enfin
bladi un coup teens est pas à son coup
d'essai il ya d'abord eu la tchétchénie
il ya eu la crimée il ya eu la géorgie
il ya eu à l'aip il ya eu la libye il ya
maintenant le mali à la centrafrique
avec wagner et bien si on laisse faire
on sait que en fait l'histoire ne
s'arrêtera pas là et donc qu'il est
c'est le moment est venu aujourd'hui le
dire non il ya un coup d'arrêt et donc
ça suppose d'être ferme pour une fois et
de ne pas laisser une fois encore des
populations dans
dans le dans le face à face avec le
régime deuxième poutine quatre l'ont
arrêté ses activités
laurent
pas fait ce que vous condamner cette
attitude comme total yannick jadot est
dit que total était complice de crimes
de guerre est ce que vous partagez ce
point de vue
l'expression est trop forte elle parlait
de complicité est ce que vous comptez
mais la présence des entreprises et oui
j'ai je condamne mais de la présence des
entreprises françaises je pense qu'elles
doivent elles aussi participer à
l'effort de solidarité que l'argent les
profits ça ne peut pas être au dessus de
toutes les valeurs qu'on défend dont et
moi j'ai appelé depuis le départ à ce
que les françaises et les français si
ces entreprises là ne font pas l'effort
que l'on leur look on en redemande et
bien de les boycotter et le considérer
qu' elles se sont mises d'une la même
façon en dehors des valeurs que nous dit
on pourra écouter ces entreprises en
france saison 6 en six ans de ses
enseignes aulas ne prennent pas les
bonnes décisions s'agit pas de lire dans
l'eure mais si elles ne prennent pas ces
décisions s'annonce pas si elle
n'annonce pas en fait qu'ils aient leur
propre échéancier si elles disent
qu'elles veulent se maintenir à tout
prix alors effectivement elle appelle
les français à boycotter ces entreprises
pour pouvoir permettre enfin pour
permettre une décision c'est pas vrai
que les emplois en france sont menacées
par les emplois qui sont en fait en
russie c'est pas il ya une espèce de
nous raconte une histoire qui n'est pas
totalement juste un sur pouvoir d'achat
christelle alors oui on disait tout à
l'heure on voit que
les conséquences de la guerre se font
sentir sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français notamment sur le prix des
denrées alimentaires qui commencent à
augmenter est ce que le chèque
alimentaires proposés par emmanuel
macron vous semble une bonne idée pour
parler aux problèmes moi je crois que la
solution elle est simple ce sont les
salaires en fait il y en a marre d'avoir
en fait une espèce de cette politique du
chéquier qui est une petite souvent
d'ailleurs clientéliste qui ne rend pas
en fait justice au travail j'ai entendu
souvent les uns les autres par les deux
de revaloriser la valeur travail est
bien la meilleure façon de revaloriser
c'est de parler des salaires et c'est
pas normal que dans notre pays on ne
parle pas des salaires alors comment on
augmente des salaires face à des patrons
qui qui ont la liberté de fixer les
salaires la première chose c'est que
déjà on augmente le smic quand on
regarde quelle a été l'évolution des
dernières années en réalité on a des
serres en haut de l'échelle qui ont
continué à augmenter plus fortement que
ceux du bas de l'échelle et l'écart
s'est creusé donc aujourd'hui quand anne
hidalgo propose d'augmenter de 15% le
smic elle propose tout bon ou tout
simplement un rattrapage par rapport à
la situation des années précédentes donc
déjà commencé bien 500 immédiatement 15%
il va y avoir des discussions notamment
avec les tpe les pme ou c'est comme jean
luc mélenchon 25 avril augmentation du
smic il faut augmenter le smic d'entrée
de jeu et ensuite il faut aller plus
loin et demander une conférence
salariale qui permettent de revisiter la
hiérarchie des salaires faire en sorte
que ce soit pas simplement au niveau du
smic mais au niveau de l'ensemble des
salaires qu'on réévalue les convives à
lui les sujets n'est pas parce que des
augmentations de tous les salaires il
n'y a pas une limite c'est à dire vous
augmentez tous les salaires quel que
soit votre salaire c'est une conférence
salariale conférence salariale c'est une
négociation tripartite entre le patronat
les syndicats et puis et l'état et donc
chacun dit ce qu'il est prêt à faire
pour permettre une évolution est
évidemment dans cette discussion on ne
plaidera pas pour que celui qui viennent
y quinze mille euros organisé c'est une
évidence c'est quoi la limite
c'est pas moi de la fixer et de
négociation est qui et qui jouera son
rôle mais l'évidence c'est qu'on ne
montera pas jusqu en haut de l'échelle
parce que la réalité c'est que ça fait
des années que en fait si on faisait en
sorte que les plus hauts salaires
n'augmentent plus et que les salaires au
contraire fait que l'argent qui leur est
distribué soit distribué aller plus bas
on augmenterait très largement les
salaires moyens dans ce pays et c'est ce
qu'il faut viser parce que vous voyez ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui quand vous
voyez les bénéfices extraordinaires qui
sont réalisés par l'entreprise du cac 40
comment ne pas s'indigner de cet écart
et qui est absolument injustifiable en
pleine crise sanitaire moment vous aviez
des français qui étaient en chômage
partiel qui perdait 16 % de pouvoir
d'achat parce qu'ils étaient 1 84% de
maintien de leur home de leurs revenus
et bien pendant ce temps là vous avez
des gens qui ont fait des bénéfices
gigantesques vous avez des fortunes qui
se sont consolidées voire même qui ont
doublé c'est absolument indécent il ya
un moment où il faut aussi remettre les
choses à leur place est ce que je me
souviens des discours enflammés du chef
de l'état appelant à de nouveaux jours
heureux en appelant aux mânes du conseil
national de la résistance rappelant que
dix ans à l'époque nous étions en guerre
et il fallait donc tous les parallèles
été fait et bien ce que je vois c'est
qu'il ya des premiers de corvée qu'on a
salué dont on a dit qu'il allait
soutenir ce pays debout et un an après
elle est bien il ne se passait rien eh
bien il est temps qu'il se passe quelque
chose il faut mettre la pression pour
que après cette élection présidentielle
oui il ya une discussion sur les
salaires alors on sait bien qu
augmentation des salaires est souvent
synonyme d'augmentation des
délocalisations comment vous vous
résolvez cette équation mais ce serait
de la folie en fait on voit bien que
notre problème aujourd'hui c'est y
compris notre souveraineté et que nous
avons payé cher le fait d'avoir à d'être
dans l'incapacité de produire des
masques des respirateurs des molécules
bref tout ce qui permettait de faire
face à une crise sanitaire
on
le voit aujourd'hui avec la guerre en
ukraine on voit bien que m y compris sur
le plan alimentaire nous avons des
difficultés car quand les gens nous
n'avons plus le blé le maïs ukrainien
oui ou russes eh bien nous sommes dans
une difficulté pour nourrir le bétail ça
a des conséquences sur le pwa d'acaht ça
est donc plutôt que de chercher toujours
à aller vers le moins disant social et
donc à délocaliser et l'évidence c'est
qu'il faut aujourd'hui relocaliser pas
de nos activités à l'échelle nationale à
l'échelle européenne pour pouvoir être
capacité de faire face à toutes les
situations n'impose pas aux patrons
français de réaliser mais en ce moment
je crois qu'ils comprennent que quand on
a délocalisé dans des pays qui sont des
pays qui ne sont pas forcément des
grandes démocraties
évidemment les salaires ils sont plus
faibles qu'ailleurs mais il ya un
problème aussi c'est que quand il ya un
conflit eh bien il ya aussi de l'argent
à perdre donc que chacun réfléchisse
sagesse mais il faut suffit non il faut
parfois être plus contraignant mais il
faut serrer semblablement aux frontières
de l'europe être en mesure de créer des
écluses qui permettent de
pénaliser en fait le bilan carbone de
desbiens qui viennent de l'extérieur et
qui en vérité à la fois participe de de
la dépréciation sociale dans notre pays
et en même temps sont la cause en fait
du réchauffement climatique et donc
c'est tout c'est tout ça se lit tout
tout ça est lié en réalité et donc oui
il est temps de penser le monde
différemment de présenter un modèle de
développement qui ne soit pas celui
qu'on connaît depuis de trop nombreuses
années car globalisation qui a eu des
effets bénéfiques parfois mais qui a
aussi des travers qui sont gigantesques
et qui à la fois paupérise les
populations les plus pauvres dans notre
pays les classes moyennes et puis aussi
sont la cause aussi d'une partie du
réchauffement climatique un mot sur la
crise sanitaire puisque les chiffres du
cor vide sont en augmentation le nombre
de cas augmente fortement on est à dix
jours du vote est ce que vous demandez
que les masques soit obligatoire dans
les bureaux de vote
obligatoire je ne sais pas en tout cas
je conseille et pas seulement dans les
bureaux de vote le bureau de vote n'est
pas le lieu où on se connaît une le plus
en réalité on y passe quelques instants
mais je vois bien que l 52 lieu
aujourd'hui où nous ne sommes plus
contraints de porter le masque et où
il ya le risque existe de recréer des
clusters demandé le retour du masque
dans certains lieux j'en appelle ce
stade à notre responsabilité collective
et je sais bien que on en a tous marre
le soma ce que ce soit je bats qui nous
a masqué beaucoup le sourire qui a aussi
empêché sa longue de liens de ce secret
nous sommes un pays latin avec le besoin
de recevoir de se parler et tout ça
toutes ces distances sont émises entre
nous nous ont beaucoup pesé mais si nous
voulons éviter un retour en flammes de
de la pandémie oui il faut en appeler la
spécialité de chacun et dans tous les
lieux est ce que le gouvernement ait eu
raison de lever les restrictions
sanitaires est ce que vous l'auriez fait
si vous étiez au pouvoir ou est-ce que
c'est irresponsable dans le contexte je
les crois qu'il ya eu donne une
coïncidence entre le moment où le
gouvernement a levé ses obligations et
puis peut-être une élection
présidentielle qui approchait et des
pâtes et papiers de penser que les mêmes
raisons et conduit à des décisions
différentes à d'autres époques mais je
comprends aussi qu'à une lassitude des
françaises et des français et que à ce à
un moment il faut aussi un peu lâché la
bride pour permettre à chacun de pouvoir
vivre le plus normalement possible mais
c'est pour ça que je dis ap longtemps
aussi responsabilités de chacun mais
faisons attention suivant les courbes je
vois que et y compris même si au micron
est plus contagieux mais plutôt moins
dangereux que les variants précédent je
vois aussi condamnation de 15 % des
soins critiques depuis une semaine donc
il ya matière à s'interroger et à faire
attention à protéger c'est les essieux
qui sont vulnérables et pour tous ceux
qui les côtoient et bien de reprendre le
masque parfois pour éviter d'être les
transmetteurs de ce virus un mot sur un
sujet qui a fait irruption dans la
campagne c'est le recours au cabinet de
conseil puisque rapport sénatorial à a
révélé qu'il y avait eu près d'un
milliard en 2021 dépensés par l'état
prend record cabinet de conseil privé ce
que c'est anne hidalgo et élus vous
engagez à ne pas avoir recours à des
cabinets de conseil privé durant le
quinquennat oui cette histoire là peut
paraître fin je vois que le président de
la république le traite avec une forme
de dessin est dit en fait au fond si les
gens sont pas faciles sommet opposant me
critique qui viennent chercher au pénal
mais la question n'est pas la question
de la légalité la question et c'est la
même on se dit mais il ne comprend même
pas ce qui lui est reprochée ne
comprends même pas que le fond du
problème c'est d'avoir au fond
privatiser une partie de la décision de
l'état ce sont des entreprises privées
aujourd'hui selon des logiques qui sont
les logiques propres au secteur privé
qui viennent maintenant définir en lieu
et place de la fonction publique ce
qu'est l'intérêt général c'est
scandaleux
des missions ponctuelles administration
peut pas sur des missions ponctuelles
pensez vraiment c'est l'émission qui ont
été rendus par mckinsey étaient des
missions qu'on ne pouvait pas remplir
est-ce qu'on avait besoin de payer un
cabinet privé pour nous dire qu'il
fallait mettre fin il fallait baisser
les apl des français alors je comprends
que mc kinsey ait fait ce choix ça
correspond à leur logique enfin c'est
quand même pas passer on est venu
frapper des français qui sont dans des
français modestes au portefeuille tout
ça sous l'égide de cabinets américains
qui sont infimes objectivité de la part
de ces cabinets de conseils qu'ils ont
un intérêt pas il manque d'objectivité
ils ont leur propre subjectivité et on
connaît en fait leur modèle qui n'est
pas le modèle
des joueuses euros pour reprendre là
encore la formule conseil national de la
résistance en fait ils sont dans une
logique énergiquement libéral
national de la résistance et la hauteur
ont été déposées depuis longtemps par
jean moulin et ses frères
vous êtes pour le maintien de la
retraite à 62 ans anne hidalgo qualifie
la réforme des manuels macron d'un jean
et d'un juste mais ce que finalement
cette réforme des manuels macron c'est
pas le prolongement de la réforme de
marisol touraine m'a pas du tout pas du
tout d'abord enfin je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi mais ensuite vous
dire aussi que en fait cette réforme
elle est purement idéologique en fait
les travaux du cor qu'est-ce qu'il nous
dise conseil d'orientation des retraites
et nous disent que
à l'horizon qui et anticipable 2070 donc
les 50 prochaines années il n'y a pas
trop de problèmes de financement de nos
retraites pas de problème de financement
des retraites pendant les 50 prochaines
années et nous disent aussi que la vente
illicite mais ils nous disent il n'y a
pas de problème de financement
on rattrapera et adem dépit des creux
comme dans tout
toutes les institutions que nous
connaissons et les moments où ça des
petits passages qui peuvent être plus
difficiles que d'autres enfin moody's à
50 ans il ya un problème de financement
et voilà un président qui nous dit voilà
dépêchons-nous 65 ans tout de suite mais
d'abord c'est pas alors je réponds à vos
questions nous n'avons pas fait la même
chose en qu'un gars raisons nous n'avons
touché à la durée de cotisation c'est
totalement différent 65 ans ça veut dire
quand même y compris des gens qu'on
cause un travail et où vont nos vies un
travail vont devoir travailler plus
longtemps emmanuel minc ruine allonge
aussi progressivement la durée de
cotisation
65 ans non quand on monte la durée
double file vous avez plus variable soit
les le montant des pensions soit l'âge
légal soit la question de la durée de
cotisation l'âge de cotisation ça veut
dire que tout le monde cotise à même
durée mais quand vous avez commencé à
travailler tôt vous partez plutôt quand
vous touchez à l'âge ça veut dire que
même si vous avez commencé à travailler
plutôt vous pour attirer plus tard
est-ce à dire que vous avez déjà en gros
qu'on va travailler tôt qui vont cotiser
plus longtemps que ce sont ceux qui ont
l'espérance de vie la plus faible donc
en réalité ils vont en profiter moins
longtemps que nos terres que les cols
bleus
vont en réalité payés la retraite des
cols blancs c'est complètement fou à 65
ans vous avez 30 % des 5 français les
plus modestes qui sont déjà décédés
alors vous avez uniquement 5 % des
français les plus riches qui sont
décédés de leur côté c'est complètement
inégalitaire et se colle au passage que
personne non personne ne parle macron
dit mais c'est pas grave moi j'aurais
aussi une genou gauche c'est cette
fameuse jambe gauche on l'attend
toujours et bien en fait cette jambe
gauche et ne viendra jamais pourquoi il
dira à 1100 euros devrait être minimal
formidable on se dit enfin pas mal quand
même c'est peut-être le donnant donnant
sauf que il falloir résoudre à voir
toutes ces années de cotisations qui
sont les gens qui ont des retraites
inférieures à ses 1100 euros le plus
souvent ce sont des gens qui n'ont pas
cette durée de cotisation donc ils
attendent quoi l'âge en fait du taux
plein automatique qui est cinq ans après
l'âge légal il est aujourd'hui de 67 ans
et voilà donc ça veut dire que 65 ans et
en fait soixante dix ans qui attendra 70
ans pour toucher ses 1100 euros alors
que vous savez très bien que la plupart
la moitié des français qui arrivent à la
retraite sont déjà en situation en fait
de schémas il n'a pas précisé si le taux
plein sera décalé à 70 ans on imagine
que si l'âge légal est à 65 ans va pas
matin à 67 ans le taux plein c'est une
évidence donc la réalité c'est que on
est dans une situation qui est
catastrophique pour une part des
salariés et que faut-il faire donc oui
il faut mettre à 62 ans mais oui il faut
aussi réintroduire les critères de
pénibilité que nous avions voté dans le
quinquennat précédent qui permettait à
des gens qui ont des tâches qui sont
particulièrement pénibles ou partition
dangereuse par exemple l'exposition
messages chimiques et c'est de partir
plus tôt à la retraite il ya 25% des
français qui sont dans cette situation
là il faut leur rendre justice c'est
aussi ça revaloriser la valeur travail
oui on est à moins de 15 jours du
premier tour anne hidalgo et toujours
autour de 2% j'ai envie de demander
qu'est ce que vous espérez encore pour
votre candidate mais ce que j'espère
tout simplement c'est que ce que nous
disons ce matin ce que dit anne hidalgo
tous les jours cette campagne qu'elle
mène avec détermination et bien la
porter ses fruits vous savez très bien
que dans le dernier
la cepal à 2017 vous avez 30 % des
français que sont déterminés notre 10
derniers jours et encore 10% dans
l'isoloir donc elle la question est là
encore devant nous pour une partie des
français et moi ce que je souhaite c'est
que chacun vienne dans cette fin dans
cette élection avec ses propres
convictions se disent voilà le vote qui
permet d'être entendu c'est celui qui
exprime ce que je crois ne pas être
toujours l'otage des sondages parce que
là aussi il ya quelque chose de
profondément dérangeant et même
peut-être d'antidémocratique vous avez
en fait depuis des mois et des mois des
sondages qui forcément orientaux thiriez
c'est son âge moi je suis favorable à ce
que disait jean pierre sueur il ya
quelques années il disait il faut qu'il
y ait une période pendant laquelle les
sondages ne sont plus publiés parce que
en réalité ils matrice complètement
notre façon de penser et aujourd'hui on
finit par croire que si on vote pour
untel ou untel ça ne sert à rien et
qu'ils vont voter pour tel ou tel la
vérité c'est que si on n'avait pas les
sondages pour nous orienter on voterait
pour ses convictions et moi je souhaite
que l'on fasse abstraction des sondages
était qu'on vote pour ses convictions
delgo à limoges a beaucoup critiqué
l'appel au vote utile de jean luc
mélenchon pourtant le ps a eu souvent
recours à cet argument de du vote utile
en 2007 en 2012 pourquoi aujourd'hui
ça ne fonctionne plus parce que anne
hidalgo disent que je dis ce que nous
disons tout et tous c'est que la
question du vote utile elle doit aussi
rejoindre la question des convictions et
est ce que aujourd'hui
si jean luc mélenchon était président il
conduirait la bonne politique pour
revenir sur la question et craignait sur
la politique étrangère que nous
souhaitons ben moi je pense que à la
fois pour ce qu'il a dit dans le passé
et je vois que il chercha à faire amende
honorable s'il fait moins honorable tant
mieux venus qu'ils évoluent mais qu'est
ce qu'il dit sur la situation actuelle
présente il dit moi président je sors de
l'otan ensuite il dit je ne livre pas
d'âme à l'ukraine et ensuite il dit je
ne vais pas sanctionner la russie pardon
mais cette façon-là de de concevoir la
politique étrangère de la france
notamment par rapport à la russie c'est
la capitulation
c'est accepter l'idée que ce soit la
paix russes qui s'imposent et moi je ne
veux pas de la paix russes et je ne veux
pas surtout décider à la place des
ukrainiens ce n'est pas un bout nous qui
sommes un pays souverain mais qui
respecte les autres pays souvent de leur
dire ce qu'il doit faire et leur dire
qu'ils doivent accepter aujourd'hui les
conditions que l'on fait venir publions
ce que le ps appelait au vote utile les
autres partis de gauche avaient
peut-être les mêmes réserves vis-à-vis
du parti socialiste et ils sont allés
voter malgré ces réserves est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous comprendriez cuillé
une union de la gauche derrière jean-luc
mélenchon même si vous formuler des
réserves importantes mais enfin pardon à
la question qui est posée aujourd'hui
c'est la question de savoir comment on
fait vivre un ensemble à gauche co
calais jean luc mélenchon s'est toujours
refusée y compris refusant même le
vocable de gauche donc je ne vois pas au
nom de et awa et pendant cinq années il
a refusé à toutes les épreuves à toute
forme de rassemblement avec l'ensemble
de la gauche doit on ne tient
aujourd'hui c'est le vote utile
pardon mais les temps sont un peu
contraint dernière question sur la
reconstruction et la reconstruction du
ps beaucoup appel à une refondation du
ps aujourd'hui vous la voyez comment
c'est quoi le ps de 2023 dans la tête de
lit les forges et avec qui
la difficulté vous répondre ce matin
c'est pas le fait que je ne sache pas ce
que je veux faire j'ai une idée très
précise de ce qu'il faut faire en même
temps je ne voudrais pas qu'on passe
notre temps à parler de la praye comme
s'il n'y avait pas un avant et je vois
qu'il ya des gens qui pendant cinq ans
n'ont jamais contribué à la renaissance
de la gauche est un parti socialiste qui
maintenant en sont déjà en janvier
l'élection présidentielle pour en
arriver à la reconstruction qui moi je
voudrais par exemple moi je voudrais
d'abord qu'on s'occupe de cette
présidentielle dire que en appeler à la
mobilisation générale pour les prochains
jours diront socialiste battez-vous
jusqu'au dernier souffle pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que d'enfin jusqu'au
dernier instant pour que
on est infléchi c'est quand même mais
bien sûr que j'y réfléchisse bien sûr
que et bien sûr qu'il faudra renverser
la table faire en sorte que nous
puissions tenir compte en tirer des
leçons pas seulement nous toute la
gauche tire les leçons de son échec
parce qu'une gauche qui est tout mouillé
fait 25% cet inédit s'est historiquement
faibles des partis politiques qui se
sont divisé jusqu'à la dernière seconde
et qui n'ont pas réussi à se mettre
autour d'une coalition pour pouvoir
gouverner ce pays dans de bonnes
conditions effectivement c'est une folie
et je crois que je me rappelle qu' il ya
à peine six mois quand ipsos ce sont des
un candidat commun des socialistes et
des écologistes il était à 18 pros c'est
à dire qu'ils étaient au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle est bien
effectivement tout ça doit nous
interroger et ivre à reconstruire sur
des bases qu'ils soient des bases
claires des bases saines sur le fond et
en même temps sortir de cette guerre de
tranchées qui a finalement un seul vin
qui n'a qu'un seul résultat c'est qu'il
ya aucun vainqueur à gauche merci merci
beaucoup olivier faure notre invité la
une de la dépêche el kobbi decaux vite
ça repart fort c'était la une de votre
journal
[Musique]